let's run deep and that's one of the
messages i had that day
when the press asked about what are we
doing let us salute president biden
right from the start within
like 24 hours of his presidency
he had executive order
calling upon the justice department even
before we had
an attorney general calling upon the
justice department to take up
this issue in a very specific way and
again
more recently his executive actions have
been very important
so let us salute him but let us do also
what the leader said
the president asked us to do to pass
this legislation it will be marked up in
committee
within the next week in our house we'll
pass it immediately
and send it over to the senate but they
have their own
version of the bill too so at some point
we'll have a meeting of the
of the legislation and to pass it to
send it on to the president
just as a matter of experience
in our community and the rest
it breaks your heart to see how
communities are affected by this these
hate crimes
and how parents are so protective of
their children
not feeling that negative
attitude i mean also the targets are
sometimes
older women women i say that as an older
woman and i say to them
when somebody is about to make some kind
of an attack
listen to what they are saying because
what they say
is what is evidence as a as a hate crime
it shouldn't have to be that high
standard if it the intent is so clear
but the fact is for now what we have to
do
is to make sure we get the words and i
said some of us who are shall
we say older don't have all of the
familiarity with some of the lingo that
people might use
and if you are again english is your
second language you might not
recognize it for the intention
that is there so again we have to do our
part
here in terms of legislation and making
the law
uh grace man in our house i speak to
this has been
relentless i've visited her in her
district and seen the beautiful
diversity of aapi in her community
and she is a magnificent spokesperson
for that but i do not have the privilege
of yielding to her is my approach deal
to our former
house member a person we take great
pride in
and no no i mean every time she speaks
we all think
she's ours she's ours she came from the
house
senator hirono thank you
thank you so much to leader schumer
and speaker pelosi i have to admit
my heart is still with the house
no offense but it is what it is
that's right everyone here served in the
house good training i have to say
and i i'm really appreciative of the
leadership shown by representatives mang
and kim in the house we know we're going
to be marking up this bill
in the house and we are going to bring
this bill on the floor of the senate
which wouldn't happen
if us leader schumer were not the leader
in the senate
former house members it makes a
difference so we've all seen
the horrific incidents of
unprovoked targeted hate crimes against
aapis
and these kinds of hate crimes have gone
up
in every single state significant
percentage of increase in targeted hate
crimes against aapis in every single
state and the dc
in dc as an api person
i do it does give me pause
if i before if i was walking around
outside i would have my earbuds on i'd
be listening to
books on tape i would never do that now
because of the incidence of totally
unprovoked
hate crimes against aapis and sadly in
the history of our country
these kinds of discriminatory actions
against aapis who are generally viewed
as
the other and therefore kind of easy to
target
but we had the chinese exclusion act we
had the
the incarceration
of 120 000 japanese americans during
world war
ii the horrific killing of vincent ching
these kinds of of discriminatory actions
are not new
but what is new is we now have a
president
who has taken responsibility who has
condemned
these kinds of crimes who has taken
action
by issuing executive memorandums by
calling on and directing the department
of justice to begin
the process or continue the process of
paying attention to these kinds of
targeted crimes
so this bill that we're bringing to the
floor
of the senate is very simple it should
be totally non-controversial
what can be so controversial about a
voluntary reporting by the states
of these kinds of crimes it's voluntary
if a state does not want to participate
they don't have to but one would hope
that there will be universal
condemnation all across the board all
across
our country by all peoples against this
kind of
targeted hate crimes so what this bill
does is it just requires
the department of justice to designate a
person who will do an expedited review
of these kinds of hate crimes
it asks the department of justice to
work in conjunction
with the state and local law enforcement
to
ensure that the word gets out in
appropriate language
culturally appropriate that these kinds
of crimes should be prevented
should be reported and it sets
up a a way where we can
report these crimes in as easy a way as
possible
so online reporting these crimes are
very much under reported as we all know
and so my hope is that we will have
republicans who will support this bill
my hope is that we will have republican
members of the house and the senate
speaking out condemning these kinds of
targeted crimes
and so we will go forward in the hopes
that
you know what an attack on one group in
our country is truly
an attack on all of us and there is no
place
in a democracy for these kinds of
unprovoked attacks
on a group of people who are only being
targeted because they
are aapis and words matter
so when you have a president who deems
the virus to be the china virus
or to have members of his administration
refer to it as kung flu you'd create an
environment
where people
will be motivated
because of whatever reasons they have to
commit these kinds of crimes
it is very important we now have a
president who speaks out
and who takes a stand it is now time for
congress
it's time for congress to take a stand
and pass this legislation against this
kind of targeted unprovoked attacks
on the apis
good afternoon everyone thank you to
majority leader schumer and speaker
pelosi for
bringing us together this morning it's
an honor to join both of you and to be
with be with my outstanding colleagues i
do want to say a special thank you to
speaker pelosi who has been very
publicly standing with the aapi
community from the very beginning when
we
started to see the increases of these
types of incidents across the country
and senator schumer my home state
senator is not exaggerating
when he says that he's been to a few
rallies
to protest this kind of bigotry he's
been at every single rally
i've been to and he's probably been to
more than that
so thank you for your solidarity you all
know that for more than a year
the asian american community has been
fighting two viruses the covet-19
pandemic
and anti-asian hate the attacks that
have been occurring against the
community have been horrifying
we've heard about and seen videos of
both young
and elderly asian americans being shoved
to the ground
stomped on beaten spat on and shunned
these heinous acts have been outrageous
unconscionable
and they must end there have been
assaults all across the nation
including in my home district of queens
new york
to help combat this bigotry and violence
i introduced legislation with senator
hirono
that would amongst other things create a
position
at the department of justice to
facilitate expedited review of covet 19
hate crimes encourage more reporting of
incidents in multiple languages
and help make different communities feel
more empowered
to come forward and report these
incidents oftentimes we tell people to
just report
if something happens to them but it's
not always so easy to do so
people might not know where the police
precinct is people might have language
obstacles
and we also need more more resources for
our local entities
to be able to figure out how to
most effectively investigate these types
of incidents as speaker pelosi said
oftentimes
the lingo and the tropes that are being
used might not be something that is
already familiar to our law enforcement
personnel this bill also directs federal
agencies to work with community-based
organizations
to find ways to talk about the covid19
pandemic
in a way that is not discriminatory i'm
thrilled that our legislation
is moving forward and i'm hopeful that
the measure will be approved by the
senate and the house
over the past year i've met with so many
asian american
community members whose lives have been
threatened
or whose loved ones have been attacked
and this bill takes into account
what i've heard from the community
people need to feel empowered
to come forward and report these
incidents we need to make that
process easier and more accessible
two weeks ago i had the opportunity to
visit atlanta georgia with our kpac
chairwoman judy chu
and also rep kim who is here today where
we met with the families of the victims
and that were killed in the mass
shooting they
all agreed in the midst of their pain
and sorrow that we need
action now over 3 800
cases of attacks have been reported
over the past year but we all know that
the number of incidents is likely higher
most of us know people who've had these
incidents happen to them at
on different levels and yet have not
reported them
so increased reporting of hate crimes
would give us more accurate data
it would give a clearer and fuller
picture of the attacks that have been
occurring
so we know what resources specifically
are needed
combating hate should not be a partisan
issue
this is about the safety of all
americans
it's about people's lives and their
right to be safe
it's about our parents and grandparents
walking down the street safely
it's about our kids being able to go to
school and play outside without fearing
that they'll be harassed
we must all as democrats and republicans
stand together against this racism and
violence and say
enough is enough we must demonstrate
that we all have
the asian-american communities back and
underscore that an
attack on the asian american community
is an attack on all of us
we have to rise up and show solidarity
against this intolerance
we have to take action to combat this
xenophobia and violence and supporting
this bill
would greatly help us achieve all these
critical goals
once again i can't thank enough leader
schumer speaker pelosi and my colleagues
for supporting this legislation and
standing with the asian american
community
and i also want to thank president biden
for endorsing this bill
and calling on congress to pass it let's
do everything in our power to
fight this racism and violence that has
plagued our community
thank you so much next i want to
introduce
representative andy kim who has been a
tremendous voice in humanizing so many
of these incidents that have been
happening
across the country
thank you everyone for coming and giving
us an opportunity to share today
i'm congressman andy kim from new jersey
we are
this week one month out from the
shootings in atlanta
and just for me personally i can tell
you this has been one of the most
difficult months of my life
a month where i've gathered with the api
community all over the country
and we shared the rawness
the vulnerabilities the fear
that we all collectively experience
this is a historic moment right now
and i want to underscore that so i'll
say it again this is a historic moment
right now
for the aapi community in america
there's never been a situation during my
lifetime that i've felt
this level of fear in this level of
vulnerability
and also the level of isolation
that i do right now
when we're down there in atlanta talking
to the victims
families as well as the broader
community
one question kept coming up
which is what are you going to do about
this
what is congress going to do about this
that is the demand being made right now
and it's a demand that is justified
given the violence and the
discrimination
that the api community has faced not
just in the last month
not just in the last year but over the
course of our entire
lives over the last month i've shared
stories i've never shared before st i've
opened up in ways that i never have
before
because the moment calls upon
i've talked about how when i worked at
the state department as a diplomat i was
banned from working on issues
related to korea because i'm
korean-american
i talked about how my five-year-old son
came home being with uh told me that a
bigger kid
kept calling him chinese boy chinese boy
over and over again as a five-year-old
this issue of foreignness and xenophobia
has been with us and i fear that
actually it could get worse as i
we know that our global competition with
china is growing
we right now at this moment
need to think about as a nation how it
is that we will embrace
and talk about and and incorporate the
aapi community in our nation
that's what this moment is i really do
believe that the next few weeks will
determine the next few decades of how
asian americans
are treated and understood and accepted
in this country
and that is the period in which my kids
will be growing up into their adulthood
so i will do everything i can
to make sure that we seize this moment
and get this passed
so when that asian american community
down there in atlanta
asks me what are you going to do about
it
next time i go back down there to
atlanta i want to be able to look them
in the eye and tell them we did
everything that we could at this moment
to try to fight for justice
and equality and allow you to be able to
feel
safe here in your own country that's
what this is about
and if we deliver anything less than
that we will have failed
this moment in time so i just ask
everyone to think about it whatever
disagreements you have or whatever
improvements or
amendments you want to make make them
but let us not fail to deliver
something here that can move our country
forward
with that i'm grateful again for the
opportunity to speak alongside
such distinguished colleagues thank you
everyone very much everyone
okay we're going to have speaker and i
are going to have to leave pretty soon
because of the memorial service so we'll
take questions on this subject first
yes ma'am
yes the bill is on the floor now
we will move a motion to proceed we're
waiting to hear our republican
colleagues haven't yet told us
what their plans are they're having
their lunch today and we hope
that they will move forward with the
bill and not block it
just go forward so we hope to get it
done this week
if we don't have real obstruction
how you balance a bill that tells doj to
more aggressively investigate and
prosecute
these the anti-asian hate crimes against
them
with reference comments last
well look we all know um we have to root
out
systemic bias in law enforcement and we
feel the best way to do that
is the justice and policing act i don't
know if it passed the house this year
but it passed it last year
and we will we are making every effort
to move it forward in the senate i will
put it on the floor for a vote
i could add something to that providing
more resources
and dedicated personnel and helping to
streamline the process
helps with data and reporting we know
that not every one of these incidents
will ultimately be charged or even
prosecuted as a hate crime
but we want to make sure that local
entities law enforcement
have the tools they need to know what is
a racist trope
what helps prove intent if there is a
hate crime that's charged
the legislation also includes components
that would
contain counseling and education if and
when someone is convicted of a hate
crime
okay yes
the language
well we'd have to discuss it we'll wait
and see for the republican lunch but we
certainly are open to amendments that
are germane and that one would probably
be germane
yes
i didn't hear the question i'm sorry
say it again is it going to be a
challenge to be collecting
after a day and potentially holding
people accountable if these crimes do
have to be specifically related
to coca-cola because that may be to
prove
intent on both racism and yeah i mean
the
intention of this bill originally was to
get a more clear and accurate picture of
what happened during this last year
during the covid
pandemic but of course this is something
that we're interested
in the long term this hate crimes
legislation doesn't only pertain and
help the asian american community it
would help all communities
before and after coveted
would put more pressure on
support it and the have support from
that you'll have to ask him i think it's
a good amendment it's needed
it's bipartisan and we'd like to see it
answer the bill
not it's not a political issue it's a
substantive issue it's a good amendment
thank you everybody
bye grace thank you
thank you austin said she was